you look like you're taking care of
yourself I'm all right you know I just
you know I don't know how much time I
have left Conan what do you mean you
know I'm not sick I'm not dying but
we're old we're getting older 50s and I
don't know when it's gonna happen
no right and you factors into my
decision-making process you like if my
my girlfriend wants to watch a movie I
don't want to watch them I don't want to
die during that can we make a better
decision I want that to be the last
thing I see what's right and more fun or
interesting your time is more precious
now you can't waste it that's right like
if someone comes out to me and says
really you've never listened to fish you
should try it I'm like I don't know how
much time I got left
yeah what if I like it that's like the
rest of my life right I don't really a
jam band yeah I don't have any more room
in my heart or my mind for another Jam
down I mean I've got like half the
Grateful Dead catalog in there and four
Allman Brothers song
yeah I'll match that all you got Phil
Dunning I'm filled
you